the head of Iran's Judiciary has
threatened to prosecute without Mercy
any women who appear in public without a
headscarf a growing number of women have
been ditching their veils after the
death of 22 year old damasa amini in
police custody last year which triggered
months of mass protests Lisa Holland is
here with me now in the glass box
um and Lisa there's this new video
hasn't there at CCTV footage that shows
just how difficult really life is for
some women who've ditched the hijab yeah
indeed and this warning from the head of
the Judiciary comes amidst some CCTV
footage which has basically gone viral
which shows really another disturbing
twist in the so-called hijab Revolution
if we have a look at the footage it
comes from the city of chandis in Iran
and if we keep an eye on the bottom
left-hand corner of the video you can
see that two women have gone into the
shop there they're approached by a man
in the Czech shirt at the back and one
woman the younger woman doesn't appear
to be wearing a headscarf at all another
is not fully covered here the man
they're reaching down throwing what we
think is a pot of yogurt first over one
woman and then over the other it seems
because they're not covering their heads
fully now we understand that the two
women were arrested for the alleged Act
of Haram which is the act of revealing
um your hair and also the man was
arrested for a public order offense as
well and this ties in what the head of
the Judiciary has said doesn't it yeah
so today the head of the Judiciary has
said that women who defy the dress code
um which is not wearing the hijab will
be prosecuted without Mercy though uh he
hasn't stipulated what exactly he means
by that but it comes as this week the
interior Ministry
urged and this this is significant I
think in the context of this video
urged ordinary citizens to confront
unveiled women which may really give you
a sense of why something like this is
happening in this city of chandis
clearly and somebody feeling emboldened
to approach two women for not covering
their heads